on a la plus grande télé la plus fine au
monde on se parle ici d'une télé 8k avec
une épaisseur de 2,9 mm alors c'est une
télé au 10 €, c'est extrêmement fin
c'est très très chouette c'est une
innovation signée à TCL on se parle ici
d'un prototype c'est un produit qui
arrivera sur le marché un peu plus tard
c'est une technologie mini laide et que
je trouve juste magnifique elle a
vraiment de la gueule oui j'en ai même
perdu la voix un téléviseur qui arrivera
potentiellement fin 2023 voire début
2024 et ce qui est intéressant est-ce
qu'on voit ici c'est que TCL m'ont
beaucoup d'innovation au niveau des
dalles au niveau des écrans et une fois
de plus ici une maîtrise vraiment l'oral
mini LED avec une finesse 2,9 mm vous
assurer que ça envoie du bois d'ailleurs
dites-moi est-ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser d'avoir une télé aussi fine
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
produits de TCL et est-ce que ça
pourrait vous botter marquez moi ça dans
les commentaires